ici on vient pour gagner de nombreux
joueurs détectés lors d'une précédente
édition c'est la quatorzième sont
actuellement pro ou semi pro on est sur
des matches des matches officiels trois
manches gagnantes donc c'est pas parce
qu'on démarre mal que le match est
forcément perdu donc il faut savoir
gérer un peu le stress savoir prendre
des temps morts
chaque joueur a le droit de poser un
temps mort d'une minute maximum durant
un match
donc il faut aussi savoir gérer ces
outils là pour parfois repartir de
l'avant et puis réussir à gagner un
match qui n'était pas forcément bien
parti paul représente l'eure et loir au
début du match contre stressé mais c'est
quand je commence à perdre et va
commencer le scénario tant redouté s'est
accomplie pour le tenir à pas en finale
à neuf ans brenda a déjà un moral à
toute épreuve
en tant qu'être cinq ans à s'entraîner
avec des joueurs plus âgés cas elles ont
hissé brinda au niveau national avec son
entraîneur
les limites nous on s'en fixe pas on
travaille dur tous les jours c'est pour
qu'ils avancent qu'ils aillent le plus
loin possible
mais avant tout qu'ils prennent du
plaisir à faire cette activité qui ait
aucune contrainte qu'ils soient contents
de venir jouer au ping pong avec nous
ils le font pour eux la france grâce à
ses jeunes espèrent un jour arracher une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
en france il ya un blanc de détection
kenny qui commence à beaucoup a bien
marché donc on peut toujours espérer
voilà on commence à concurrencer sur les
catégories jeunes et asiatiques et bien
espérons que oui ces deux générations la
soif de grands joueurs ont connu les
larmes avant la gloire
perdre n'est pas le bout du monde
[Applaudissements]